he's like such an amazing father I'm so
lucky he's my baby's daddy like he's so
incredible Cameron Diaz is opening up
about quarantine life with her hubby
Benji Madden and their new baby I love
being a mother it's the best best best
part of my life the actress joined her
gal pal who what we're CEO Kathryn power
on Instagram live Tuesday and she dished
on how she's spending time with her man
and their daughter three-month-old
radek's while in quarantine
amid the corona virus pandemic I've kind
of been living a quarantine life anyhow
because I have but three months older
three and a half month old yeah so I my
life has been completely like quiet and
still for the last few months and having
you know just have but I was able to
have like all my friends over all the
time right you know and now I don't see
anybody but Cameron admits she kind of
likes it I love it though I can I love a
bubble it's so dope yeah I love being
like in the womb of my home and like
with my family and with my husband and
like cooking and yeah you know it's just
so good but at the same time it's like
crazy to think that there's you can't
actually go out into the world if you
want to do right now the lovebirds
welcomes their little girl into the
world on December 30th and share the
exciting news weeks later on Instagram
while the couple has always been pretty
private the 47 year old couldn't help
but fawn over mommy hood and her amazing
husband I love being a mother it's the
best best best part of my life
I couldn't even like I'm so so so
grateful and so happy and it's just the
best thing ever and I'm so lucky to get
to do it with Benj and we're just having
the best time it's it's so great it's
I'm just thrilled I can't believe it
cute as for how she's spending her time
at home well it's relatable AAF I'm
either cleaning cooking or taking care
of my baby like well and usually all of
it at the same time I'm sure all the
mamas out there feel
you can yes I drink every night it's my
wine down for the day where I go in
after we've done bath time with our baby
and like put her down to sleep
I Benj puts her to bed like he's so good
he's like such an amazing father I'm so
lucky he's my baby's daddy like he's so
incredible so he puts her down and I go
into the kitchen and I start dinner and
I I do I pour myself a nice glass of red
wine and I start my cooking I put on my
show whatever it is and just like the
rest of us cams been deep cleaning her
house taking on one room at a time and
she's fighting the blues and worried
about the state of the world by staying
in the present and not letting herself
overthink and get scared I stay present
I stay here in the here and now what I
can affect what I can do on a daily
basis to take care of myself take care
of my family the furthest I think out is
like two weeks so because right now to
get anything into the house it takes a
couple of weeks to really like get what
you need yeah other than that like I am
in the moment here being so grateful
that I am healthy
[Music]